ich halte es für dringend notwendig für
diskutieren geht schon seit drei jahren
darüber dass solche gefährlichen leute
tatsächlich auch obwohl syrien nach wie
vor bürgerkriegsland ist abgeschoben
werden können
es ist verständlich dass wir diejenigen
die als flüchtlinge zu uns gekommen sind
die sich hier gut integrieren die
anerkannt sind als flüchtlinge dass wir
die nicht wieder nach syrien schicken
aber wer auch wenn jetzt bürgerkrieg ich
sehe hier bei uns schwerste straftaten
mehr an droht das in wieder zeuge
straftaten begehen will der muss nach
syrien zurück geführt werden und ich
habe wirklich gerade angesichts dieser
taten null verständnis dafür dass wir
uns jetzt schon seit drei jahren mit
spd-ländern in der
innenministerkonferenz herumstreiten
darüber und immer wieder gesagt wird
nein das sei nicht vertretbar und und
und wir sehen welche christliche
auswirkungen das haben kann und deshalb
muss dieses thema jetzt bei der nächsten
innenministerkonferenz die in wenigen
wochen stattfinden wird auf jeden fall
behandelt werden
ich werde auf jeden fall in einem
allgemeinen abschiebestopp nach syrien
nicht noch einmal zustimmen
klare worte von ihnen hat denn ihr
kollege roland wöller sachsens msa
fehler gemacht oder vielleicht sogar mit
schuld angesagt grausamen tat
nein das gar nicht mehr kennen aber ich
will jetzt auch diese einer sächsischen
vorgängen nicht weiter kommentieren dazu
fehlen ja auch die hintergrund
kenntnisse aber was klares ist also ist
ein bundesweites thema es gibt leider
immer noch diese bundesweite
entscheidung dass generell keine
abschiebungen nach syrien stattfinden
das soll für flüchtlinge der normale
flüchtlinge auch gerne weiterhin gelten
aber wir müssen zusammen mit dem bund
und da muss sich auch das auswärtige amt
bewegen
da muss sich andere entsprechende auf
bundesebene mit engagieren wir müssen
klarmachen schwere straftäter
gewalttäter gefährt der gefährliche
leute die müssen auch wieder nach syrien
zurück geschickt werden können
es gibt durchaus teil von syrien wohl so
jemand nicht sofort wieder tut es gefahr
droht wir können es uns
nicht zumuten dass derweilen die todes
gefahren für die bürger in deutschland
bestehen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren